Oh
now
so I noticed that there's this little
M&M peeking out of this trail mix bag
and I thought it was a dart a little
nerf die I was like oh oh it's just M&M
and then it got the look is like why is
there like a random little nibbled hole
in this bag so check this out
what does this look like to you I don't
want to make any broad statements but we
have so many rats right now what we're
brats dude or mice rats are outside my
Center yo but what if a mouse goes
outside does it become a rat in a
faretta in the house is it a mouse I no
see no mouse outside that's something
that's because it's a rat food hey no
it's just how Carmichael eats what is
Rick I've never seen any rodents here we
don't have any other evidence
worst case scenario how does this play
out we're all dead in six months is what
it means
yeah what do you think this is it looks
like bite marks on what do you think
caused that hole Munchkins so we're
gonna set up a time lapse overnight and
see if we can catch any mice or rats or
peters or whatever it may be there's
2,000 photos it was going all night
watch the M&Ms and they moved that leads
me to believe oh oh oh there yeah wait
wait wait wait wait there's a rat in
Everest he lives on my desk that's not
sanitary
but you're a rat living on your desk bro
look dude don't you
right right
what the hell you dress like this Ford
I'm a goon son oh my god I can't believe
it do negative work take a snapchat does
he live over here does he climb up there
he makes multiple trips you can see him
eating yeah he's pretty cute we'll see
if he uh you want to see in the rear I
got it on time laughs yeah we got him on
camera man whoa
[ __ ] little cute guy why was Nick
recording a time-lapse of the corner of
his desk to catch catch the rat lets me
put a bounty on his head
what 20 bucks under 3 the river
countries are rap so I get a six-pack
any beer of their choice all right he'll
show you could lead me into a dark room
this is a trick I've no idea what this
is this is just an ambush Wow son of a
[ __ ] so titles and terrain this is the
modular stuff so it's actually super
awesome the city builder stuff all the
previous sets came and just kind of just
general squares you just slide them
together but their latest set comes with
very very very well designed basically
posts as you can see here these things
plug into the walls here and allow you
to create structures these multiple
stories you can do
so right here it's drapes for the window
are you forgetting their great got
drapes Saturday I would literally never
buy real drapes but I would get
miniature drapes anything honestly I'm
just totally blown away I want to give a
huge shout out to form Forge thanks guys
for getting us some of this gear and I
cannot wait to start using this in the
videos if you guys haven't checked out
their site do it now
they make the best stuff so we have a
mouse living in our house been chewed
out here some dust all over the ground
here from it I haven't have two very
good mouse traps next door they go by
the names of Corey and roto you guys
just alerted me that Jan is coming by
yeah
Brightman Oh hahaha I'm getting good
until you two win and then he shot me in
the face
hi guys how's it going I got shot her in
the neck
now with the rat running around and now
quarry hunting it somewhere in the
studio figured I could make a rat trap
for this DIY rat trap we're going to
need a few things
this rod that I found peanut butter nice
little water bucket just gonna be my
pilot hole so we're not gonna drown the
rat instead it's just gonna go to the
farm where our first two cats live and
all the Peters live
hey there we go yay ready to smear
peanut butter all over this bottle yep
do we have any people we do peanut
butter dry in front of you Hey oh man
why you got to do that man
she's got peanut butter everywhere dude
really though no you cleared it up oh
there was a fly in my wine I was
drinking last night I just spit it out
on the table I was having a fine vintage
it airborne insect made its way in my
esophagus wreck I toned it man
nothing did you check it yeah
time-lapse shows that he wasn't even
there one last thing to do good Amazon I
hope this is the big one
so Carmichael bought some rat traps and
they set him around and it's been a
couple days now but there's nothing we
put out four of them two upstairs one
here and then one in between me and
Carmichael's desk where we found the rat
Nico thinks that the rat has literally
just left the studio since we took away
all the food
maybe we'll we'll never catch them
that's probably for the best for all of
us
come back it will happen
god no it's so big he's like dead people
might give us some prep for using a
lethal rat trap let's be honest
so rodent spread disease I put poop
everywhere they get your food they can
make you very sick also for what it's
worth it's a humane rat trap meaning
there's spikes in the bar and the bar
closes on that rat it's going to
instantly just break its spine and
pretty much lights out instantly well I
already solid indent in that pencil
that's pretty much an instant guillotine
for a rat now we have to clean it up we
should do now watch our favorite Disney
movie ratatouille it's not my favorite
all right listen learned rat traps work
confirmed